i think for me as the host producer
friend psychologist that i am
it allowed me to do my job better the
former bachelor host according to a
report
threatened to spill nearly 20 years of
dirt if he didn't receive a 25 million
dollar payout
news of his exit got a little awkward
this morning on gma
there was a settlement a buyout for him
to leave now i'm just wondering how much
i would pay me to step away
oh that wasn't funny i'm sorry harrison
had originally told michael strahan
he wanted to keep his job i plan to be
back and i want to be back
so what changed well harrison's team
reportedly became quote
outraged with a lack of network support
the man who helped him get millions
attorney brian friedman who represented
megyn kelly in her 69 million
exit deal from mbc and gabrielle union
when she left agt
over accusations of workplace toxicity
chris who came under fire for minimizing
a contestant's racist behavior
has been with the franchise for 19 years
hi i'm chris harrison and no i'm not the
bachelor
and was a co-executive producer on
bachelor in paradise
i like to picture how my show's going to
play out and you you know that's what
producers do
so what's next for the former host well
he could be moving to austin texas where
he's building a house
we're also told he's getting calls about
new projects
but fallon had jokes right now he's
editing his resume like matchmaker with
19 years experience
and three successful couples
as for his endorsement deals while
harrison has been scrubbed from the
website of wedding ring maker
manly bands last year he worked with
seagram's to create a
canned tropical rose come with me to a
world of delicious possibilities
but we've learned that was a limited run
that ended last summer still
as of this morning the 49 year old had
an active profile on cameo
a site that allows fans to pay
celebrities to send messages